Jay Winik author of April 1865 the month
that saved America where did you get the
idea for the book where did I get the
idea for the book well you know
originally I was before I wrote April
1865 I was writing a book on the end of
the Cold War and in the process of that
I started doing some research and
reading on other wars just to get
insights and parallels from previous
conflicts and in the course of that in
reading about the Civil War several
things happened firstly I got to run and
you know I became one of these you know
what you would call a Civil War buff
secondly it occurred to me in the
process of this that Robert II least
surrenders yet he surrenders only his
army there's still three Confederate
armies in the field we'll get to that
later on
five days later Lincoln is dead and I
thought you know from my previous life
when I worked in defense and foreign
policy I used to be an adviser to les
aspin Bill Clinton for Secretary of
Defense and I had been involved in a
number of civil wars myself most
especially the conflict in Cambodia
which I had a great deal of work with it
occurred to me that's a story there and
I wanted to look at that and in fact
nobody really quite looked at it that
way in in effect what I was asking is
the question of how Wars end is every
bit as important as why they start or
how they're fought put differently far
too many civil wars throughout history
and quite badly think of Northern
Ireland that's going on for some 200
years think of Lebanon Rwanda Cambodia
think of the horrors of the Middle East
or the Balkans today our civil war could
have ended just as badly with the same
terrible tragic consequences but didn't
why that's the question I wanted to
answer in which I do answer in April
1865 you were the first person on the
ground after the killing fields in
Cambodia not the first person on the
ground but I was on the first person to
go back to Cambodia in an official
airplane since actually since a the
killing fields and since we broke off
relations it was really quite a trip we
didn't know who we'd meet with I had to
go meet with the Vietnamese the day
before in Thailand to make sure that we
wouldn't be shot down and we didn't know
how long we'd be there we didn't know
what kind of reception we get you
couldn't telephone you certainly
couldn't email you certainly couldn't
fax it was really a black halt Baco
removed from the rest of the world in a
civil war was raging there literally
when we landed and it was a fascinating
trip but one of the things that this
work in in other foreign civil wars
stimula
was a real interest in our civil war
what are some of the other civil wars
you've seen up close compelling yeah
I've been to I've been to the Civil War
Nicaragua when during the sandanista
period I've been to the civil war in El
Salvador and during that Civil War I
still vividly remember being in an
armored car with a lead car in front of
us and a chase car behind us and we had
a sort of garrison two machine guns
protecting us because the civil war was
so raging out of control and that was
another civil war I'd been to I had been
to the former Yugoslavia as it just just
as it was about to dissolve and I also
saw the sort of dissolution of the
Soviet Union not quite a civil war but
it has variations of it and had a
fascinating fascinating several weeks
where I met with black valensa
Yaroslavsky who was the commander who
was the president at communist President
of Poland we went through Czechoslovakia
and we just went through all of Eastern
Europe as was dissolving it was really
history at its making and I felt
privileged and excited to be there and
and it also gave me an enormous pool to
draw upon when I would later sit down to
write this book what do you do down a
full-time basis um yeah that's what my
father wants to know and if we were
discussing that earlier I now write full
time I used to be in government I worked
with the Foreign Relations Committee the
Armed Services Committee I I advised les
aspin who was the first secretary of
defense for Bill Clinton I made a
decision when the Cold War ended that I
wanted to do something different I came
to Washington not to have a job but to
do a job and when the Cold War ended I
wanted to do something sir that would
mark that would challenge me and know
and that became writing and the first
book I wrote was about the end of the
Cold War it was called on the brink and
then I hit upon this idea for April 1865
and the last the last four and a half
years that's all I've been doing I get
up every day I have the same schedule I
have the same routine and I either
research or I write and and at this
point I really couldn't imagine doing
anything else in both administration's
the Clinton administration and the Bush
administration people said to me you've
got a lot of context you know a lot of
people you've got the background why
don't you go into the administration and
at this point I just couldn't imagine
doing it I love writing and I hope to
continue doing it there's that you read
the endogenous there's a conflict to try
to figure out where you might be coming
from politically one of your favor
people Stephen so Lars a former
Democratic congressman and also this is
underwritten by the Bradley Foundation
which is often known to underwrite
conservatives help me out on the
ideology thing right well the ideology
for April 1865 is there is no ideology
I've been in Washington a long time I
you know I'm fairly well-connected in
both parties and with people of all
political stripes
Steve so ours is somebody who I worked
with extensively during the Cambodia
crisis and I've come to know him quite
well we played tennis together and I
think the world of them I think he's a
terrific guy and a wonderful statesman
in America the Bradley Foundation has
been helpful to me in providing
additional research monies it's always a
question with authors do you have enough
no matter how much money you get paid
and I got a nice advance for this but it
always runs out and and they were really
very nice and generous and assisting me
what's important one point I want to
stress is the ideology for this book is
nothing I want to write for all readers
I don't want to turn off liberals I
don't want to turn off conservatives
really what I did is I sat down with a
kind of a fresh eye and a fresh vantage
point and I said what's the story and
and that's what I set out to do what do
you get in your book that you don't get
in all the other thousands of books that
are written about Abraham Lincoln for
starters yeah yeah well well you
certainly hit your nail you hit the nail
on the head there because more books
have been written about the Civil War
than any other topic there is except for
the Bible and of course when I started
out everybody said to me well you're not
a civil war historian per se what do you
have to say and and and that was kind of
the challenge and I mean indeed it was
sort of heretical that I would take on a
body of literature were so many good
scholars have written so many wonderful
and fine books from James McPherson the
Shelby Foote to Garry Gallagher and
onward yet having said that because of
my defense and foreign policy background
I think I brought to it a kind of
freshness of eye and a freshness of
appreciation and in this this idea of
how war's end being is every bit as
critical as why they start and how
they're fought this was really one of
those few areas that has really not been
mined extensively with this kind of I
one other thing I do in April 1865 which
is a little bit different is I strip
away the inevitability of events so that
rather than seeing it with a comfort of
136 years or 140 years of hindsight used
the events as they take place you see
the decisions as they see them you see
the turning points as they see them and
you see how easily events could have
just as just as easily gone one way or
gone another way and it's that kind of
richness of history that I wanted to
bring alive back in the back on page 376
I'd like to say I'd know it by heart but
I don't know I'll read this to you
because I think it touches on so many
things I want you to talk about right
you do the what if yeah what if this
happened rather than that what if Lee
had found an abundance of food at Amelia
courthouse and safely made his way south
to link up with Joe Johnston explain
that yeah no this is this is one of the
great moments in American history and
it's fascinating it's filled with drama
the setting that is taking place is as
follows Richmond and Petersburg have
just fallen and robert e lee with his
with his a great army of northern
virginia having bested or eluded every
other Union General before them now has
got trying to hook down south to meet up
with General Joe Johnston another
Confederate General he has a one-day
leap on the Federals on u.s. grant and
his goal at this point is he's going to
hook down south link up with Johnston
they will strike out of all people bill
Sherman and at that point they will take
to the hills and as robert e lee once
said if he can get to the Blue Ridge
Mountains he could continue the war for
another 20 years and and and far from
being disputed when Petersburg and
Richmond fell the men were actually
quite elated the spirit was high their
morale was high because robert e lee had
performed miracles before and so they
believed once out on the open he could
do it again that was out in the open
where he was his most aggressive was out
in the open where he was at his most
audacious what was the timing on this at
the time was this was after April 2nd it
was April 2nd leading until April April
9th when here in that last most you are
now last month Annette thank you in that
last month in in the final four weeks
and and yet this retreat is contingent
upon one thing they need food they leave
without food so they're marching in the
heat of the Virginia Sun they're
marching in a cool of the Virginia
nights
hour after hour after for a day and a
half straight and eventually they come
to the small little sleepy village
called Amelia courthouse it's got its
got spanking white picket fences and
weathered cottages weather cottage
houses and tumbled roses running over
the wall
and thousands of men descend in and
eventually Lee himself comes in there
and he let out this loud lust each year
because this is the moment they've all
been waiting for they're going to find
food they will rest and then he will
move down south and continue this war
Lee gets to the train which has the food
waiting for 350,000 rations they open it
up and what do they find they find guns
they find cannon they find caissons they
find weapons they find everything but
food they find everything but tea they
find everything but water a mere
administrative mix-up has threatened to
undo this mighty Army of Northern
Virginia as much as any of the Union
generals before them these are the
quarks and the turns of the wheel of
history what if he had decided that
honor lay not in surrendering but in
fighting on and on for mother south with
organized guerrilla warfare yeah
it's the this this we should discuss in
a little bit of detail the month of
April 1865 actually starts out let's not
take it in the South but let's move it
into the north for a second a meeting
that Abraham Lincoln has with his two
top generals u.s. grant and Bill Sherman
he wants to talk about the war when it
will end what will happen how would
happened and one of the first things he
says to grant is he says you know much
more blood be shed must there be a final
bloody Armageddon and of course picture
Lincoln for a second just imagine it in
your mind's eye he is so exhausted and
worn by this ongoing tornado and
wreckage of war he is 30 pounds
underweight his hands are routinely cold
and clammy he is so sick of this ongoing
war he has recently held a cabinet
meeting from his bed so he says to grant
much more blood be shed
grant shakes his head sadly and says Lee
being Lee Robert Ely the commanding
general of the Confederate armies being
Lee more blood will be shed and then
Lincoln talks about his other great fear
that is haunting him he says he worries
about them taking the Confederates
taking off into the hills with their
hearty horses and hearty men in other
words guerrilla warfare that was the
option that lay before the Confederates
and that's what that's what Lincoln
feared it's what grant feared it's what
Sherman feared and of course when Lee
was about to be surrounded he was
surrounded in a north south and east and
west every direction but North it's at
that point where he convened a council
of war and in his council of war when I
was top aides EP or AP Alexander one of
his most trusted aides I should say says
you know we can
to the hills like partridges and rabbits
and a little more bloodshed now will
make no difference in other words what
he is talking about is he was talking
about guerrilla warfare he is talking
about what Jefferson Davis the
Confederate President was calling for
guerrilla and partisan warfare in other
words what he was talking about in
effect was the vietnamisation of america
and this was a decision that lay before
robert e lee what if Lee had responded
to surrender not with dignity and honor
but with rage yeah yeah it's uh it's
fastening you know we're we're speaking
in the year 2001 and while I don't want
to date ourselves the fact is if we look
at the Middle East there these conflicts
are kind of spiraling out of control and
with every act of violence it seems to
beget more violence and of course in the
case of Robert Ely he was the moral
conscience of the south he was as
general wise one of the one of his top
men once said to him and wise was also a
former governor of Virginia near the end
of the war they were talking about what
will happen next and and and wise had
written through the lines he dismounted
his horse and he's actually fallen in
Virginia quicksand and he was caked with
red mud and he looked kind of ridiculous
well they joked a bit but then they
talked about the end of the war and
least of raises this dreaded concept of
surrender and he says what will the
country think and wise looks overt of
Lee and he says country my god man you
are the country to these men so in other
words Lee was the country to the
southerners and whether or not he would
decide to deal with the northerners with
honor and dignity and to become good
citizens again or with rage and
continued civil war and civil violence
he would be the determine of that that's
what I'm talking about there or if grant
and Sherman had neglected Lincoln's
admonitions at City point and responded
not with generosity of spirit but with
unbridled anger where is City point and
when was Abraham Lincoln there yeah yes
City point is uh is in Virginia and it's
where US Grant the commanding general of
the Union armies where he had his
floating his floating fortress city camp
was in effect an armed command post for
the northern army as they weren't
circling the Lee's army in in Petersburg
and in Richmond
and they met it on March 27th in March
28th where Lincoln will actually wanted
to see the frontlines and confer with
his commanding generals and it was from
City point that that Lincoln in the same
meeting that he talks about his fears of
guerrilla warfare in the same meeting
where he talks about his fear that this
there would be a final bloody Armageddon
he does something quite unique Abraham
Lincoln says says when this war is over
there must be no hangings there must be
no bloody work and of course what is
what is sort of looming large in his
mind is the specter of the French
Revolution because it wound large on the
minds of all Americans and of course to
remind our listeners and our viewers
here in a French Revolution the
revolutionary started out with the best
of intentions and before everybody knew
what they were guillotining the
opposition before everybody knew what
they were guillotining each other and
before everybody know it would engulf
all the continent and in effect what
Lincoln was saying is there must be no
french revolution here it was prescient
and it was visionary it was one of
Lincoln's finest acts and finest moments
and grant would carry it out brilliantly
at Appomattox during the surrender where
rather than treating treating Lee like a
defeated dishonor foe he would treat him
with great dignity and grace and it
would be one of the most poignant scenes
really in our history
we're in Washington DC if you had to go
to Appomattox how would you get there
from here uh you let my wife drive you
know you you would I mean I can't tell
you the exact highway but it's about
three and a half hours from Washington
DC and Appomattox is one of these sleepy
little places that does not get nearly
enough attention but it is well worth
going because it's an ad Wednesday in
Virginia I'm sorry in Appomattox in the
best way to do it is really you can go
to Richmond first and you can actually
do a little tour of Richmond you can
serve recreate the burning of Richmond
has happened on April 2nd and April 3rd
in 1865 and from there you can go down
to Cold Harbor and you can see the the
Grassley fighting of 1864 and then you
can actually do Lee's retreat and they
have it marked out in Virginia and and I
did it I mean I did it with my wife we
drove it we walked those fields we
walked those roads we actually sort of
did it on the day that we did it and
people can do it now and it's it's just
wonderful I mean you really are
transported back in time and it's a trip
well worth taking back to the what ifs
or if there had not been an honor
stacking of arms and mutual salute to
set the tone for the end of the war but
hangings and humiliation yeah yeah this
was one of the crossroads throughout
throughout history far too many civil
wars and with that sort of bloodshed
with with hangings or killings or
beheadings in fact just think about it
the morning that that Lee has made this
fateful decision that he's going to
surrender at that point he starts
treyton to himself up and he says and
now he must go meet General Grant and
I'd rather die a thousand deaths than do
that history has morph into not
telescoped and simplified what happens
they have simplified it to say that
there is a Lee's vain quixotic retreat
they've said then there's the dignity of
Appomattox end of war end of story and
truth is far richer let's ask the first
question
how would we be treated when he goes to
meet us grant he didn't know what what
what we do know is leave that morning
was actually quite nervous
uncharacteristically so he was speaking
and mumbled half sentences and well he
should have been nervous because because
throughout history as he knew all too
well
defeated generals and revolutionaries
and traders were typically beheaded or
they were hung or they were imprisoned
or like the general Napoleon they were
exiled and in fact that very morning at
very morning the Chicago Tribune
editorialized hang Lee in just a zur Lee
ER in a union capital of Washington DC
Andrew Johnson the vice-president of the
Union went out with several senators
before thronging crowd of hundreds maybe
over a thousand and gave a rousing
speech in which he said we must hang
davis we must hang Lee we must hang them
20 times so in fact we didn't know what
to expect and that grant would treat him
with such tenderness and dignity and
it's such a rich scene he was carrying
out Lincoln's vision at City point of
nobody work no hangings but it was
really unique in the chain of history
I have talking about your book because
some friends of the day and somebody
said well Lee and grant knew each other
well at West Point
well you address this in the book yeah
yeah they didn't know each other well at
West Point but what what is interesting
is the sort of bonds that are forged
forged in war and and let me set the
scene for a second to explain this let's
go to the wilderness for a second
because this is where the wilderness is
the six week campaign in 1864 before
they begin
the siege in Richmond and Petersburg and
is where Lee and grant squared off for
the first time in the first two days of
the wilderness grant loses 17,500 men he
goes into his tent at night and he weeps
like a baby and the next morning when he
comes out everybody expects him to do
what every other Union General had done
or treat memorably Grant says we will
fight it out if it takes all summer of
course it will take all year just a few
weeks later at Cold Harbor in the first
nine minutes alone grant will lose ten
thousand men that is twice as many men
who will die of all the Confederates in
the entirety of the Gettysburg conflict
and and he does it within ten minutes
and in his entire 6-week skirmish grant
was as many men as Lee has in his entire
army and he will lose as many men as we
will lose in the entirety of the Vietnam
War so out of this ghastly warfare this
bloody battling the irony is is that
these two men came to respect each other
too almost to fear each other and to
admire each other and the difference in
age the difference in age is Lee is
about 58 and grant is is I think 43 so
they didn't even come close it was they
did they didn't even come close to West
Point but interestingly enough when he
first walked into Appomattox Courthouse
Lee is wearing his finest uniform
because as he said and now I must become
general Grant's prisoner that day and
Grant who keeps him waiting for thirty
minutes comes in in a mud spattered
privates place in fact later on in
history he will apologize for how he's
attired and you know picture this scene
for a second a small little home Wilmer
McLean house in Appomattox Courthouse is
a little village of about eight
structures or so in rolling hills and
outside these rolling hills are
thousands of men who are standing at
rapt attention to watch this amazing
piece of historical theater to take
place in fact you know when the
surrender is over I'm going to digress
for a second everything will be ripped
apart from the wildermann clean house
that the des depends the floorboards the
the wallpaper even a tree that Lee
himself will have leaned against that
morning will be ripped apart so there's
nothing except for a hole there because
everybody knew that day that history was
taking place and they wanted a piece of
it and so they were standing at rapt
attention but inside a small little in
the small little home grant comes in
and you know rather than talking about
the surrender they talk about the old
days and I think this is what your
friends are referring to expand says you
know I remember you from New Mexican War
and what does Italy do he looks at him
and he says you know all these times in
this battle I've tried to recall your
face I could never quite do it and in
fact they continue to chat happily and
in Grant tells us that that they
continued on and on and was eventually
lee who says I suppose we must discuss
the object at hand the surrender so
though they didn't know each other that
kind of bond the bonds that were forged
in the closest they had almost defies
the fact that they were the greatest of
nemec's one could imagine back to the
what is what if Andrew Johnson had been
assassinated after all and the blade
hadn't missed its mark of sewers jugular
yeah yeah let's let's set the stage for
a second the first thing to remember is
that on April 9 as we were discussing
robert e lee surrenders to us grant this
dignified honorable surrender yet it yet
he only surrenders his army there are
still three confederate armies in the
field there are over a hundred and
seventy-five thousand men their
murderous gun barrels hot to the bitter
end there is Jefferson Davis the
Confederate president calling for
guerrilla warfare and and even Mary Lee
robert e lee's wife mary lee who is
directly descended from martha
washington the great-granddaughter and
by marriage of course to George
Washington she says robert e lee is not
the Confederacy Richmond is not the
Confederacy
that's how volatile the still the
situation still is and of course as
Lincoln feared how much longer would the
war last a week three weeks three months
six months was Lincoln knew and feared
throughout history such time spans had
been enough to start fighting win wars
to unseat great dynasties or to
complicate the reconciliation to come
and five days later Lincoln is dead he
gets killed in April 14th at 10:14 at
night and William Seward the Union
Secretary of State estab five times his
wife is soon screaming they murdered my
son they murdered my husband and only
Andrew Johnson escapes unscathed
but the irony of that night is is Andrew
Johnson was invited at all of all places
Ford's Theater he turns it down saying
you know I'm tired I want to have a
quiet little supper and in turn in and
he does this and not real
sizing that in a very for above him in
his hotel is another deadly assassin
who's going to punch a knife into his
heart but at the last second the
assassin gets cold feet and so Johnson
escapes but had Johnson been
assassinated that night there would have
been a completed decapitation of the
Union government for those who are old
enough to remember that the the horror
and the trauma of just Kennedy getting
killed in one of the most established
and oldest and most formed democracy in
the world imagine as the first-ever
assassination of a president in American
history the Secretary of State's been
stabbed five times and the Vice
President was also a mark I just saw the
the knife it's on display in Fort Wayne
at the Lincoln meal in there and so on
it's headed on loan there an
assassination exhibit and it's
interesting all these years later that
knife is still intact what was that all
about five times the Secretary of State
was stabbed by whom yeah yeah his name
was Lewis Powell and he went by a number
of aliases from Lewis Paine to a number
of other names he was a big hulking man
who wears a broad hat and in the setting
of that night was was Lewis Powell was
dispatched by John Wilkes Booth who of
course is the murderer of Abraham
Lincoln that the same night and at the
same time and Powell arrives at the
Union Secretary of State's house knocks
on the door and he pretends to be
carrying carrying medicine for for the
Secretary of State Seward and a reason
why that is a Seward had just been it up
excuse me a horse accident I mean I got
carriage accident he had been knocked
out and he was in a neck brace lying
down and so the irony is is that when
when Powell went through the house and
was stabbing one person after another
and finally finds the ailing Secretary
of State he stabs him once twice in
three and five times what we know or
what is clear is he stabbed a number of
times the neck brace and that is the
only reason why why Seward wasn't killed
what did you do to get a grip on the
whole story of the assassination Ford's
Theatre and John Wilkes Booth how'd you
learn it yeah yeah I learned it the way
I learned everything else a couple of
ways firstly there's a rich body of
literature out there and I tried to
become as acquainted and as intimately
oh now
eligible about this body of literature
as possible number of many good books
and I hesitate to name them for fear of
omitting several good ones secondly I
went to the places I went to the places
and again I tried to recreate it I went
to Ford's you know for example at Ford's
Theatre they talked about how John
Wilkes Booth after he shot after he shot
um Abraham Lincoln he serve jumped from
the balcony and he screamed you know six
Samper Tyrannosaur death to tyrants and
and it's often said that that was an
easy jump especially for an athletic man
like booth well I took a look at that
that that balcony and I played tennis
and I played a number of sports it was
clear to me there was anything but an
easy jump so in other words actually
going and as we used to say in a defense
business to actually go out and kick the
tires and to try to relive it to try to
sort of feel it that's that that was
very important and crucial for me to get
a sense of that night and just the way I
did in Richmond when I tried to recreate
the burning of Richmond I really tried
to kind of walk the streets and follow
the same pads to get a feel for what it
must have been like you know for example
one point John Wilkes Booth will cross a
significant body of water well it sounds
pretty easy unless you actually try to
do it yourself and you know if you try
to also serve be on the hunt the whole
time so I really tried to capture that
as much as I could the fourth theater
just ten blocks from where we're sitting
yeah right across the street the
Petersen house you also recreate that
whole nagas the he died would you say
7:20 to the next morning did you find
anything new could you just try to tell
the story as you found it other places
yeah you know it's some of the details
that I use I think are different and
that's not to say I found anything new
but I just sort of saw a new some of the
details that have already been out there
but again I want to go back to one of
the original things I started up by
saying what I do in April 1865 is I
strip away the inevitability of events
more often than not when you when you
have books on the assassination of
Abraham Lincoln
it's totally separate from the story of
the end of the war so in fact most
people don't realize that Lincoln was
assassinated just five days after the
surrender of Lee and most people also
don't realize there was still three
Confederate armies out in the field that
guerilla war was a real possibility and
that all sorts of things could have
happened
to complicate the reconciliation one
other thing that really struck me that
night in the Peterson house when link
when Lincoln Lay Dying
is you know we've been hearing a lot
these days about Alexander Haig during
the attempted assassination of Ronald
Reagan saying I'm in control here and
how that was seen as a really rogue act
well on the night of April 14th and in
April 15th when Lincoln had died from
this small small little room in the
center of the Petersen house the
Secretary of War for the Union Edwin
Stanton was literally running the
country he had become the President the
Vice President the Secretary of War the
Secretary of State and a comforter in
chief all wrapped into one and and it
shows you just how different the world
day inhabited it was from ours what did
you learn about Mary Todd Lincoln and
her reaction to the assassination yeah I
mean I mean I have to say that it really
sort of struck a chord of both poignancy
and pathos in me because you know her
husband has just been shot I mean his
brain his brains have been essentially
been blown out before her eyes and that
night she was weeping and wailing by his
side and at one point again to show the
power of Edwin Stanton the Secretary of
War she had so gotten out of hand at at
one juncture he screams take that woman
out of there and you know you can
imagine this happening with Hillary
Clinton it would never happen but in
fact she was actually removed to the
front room of the Petersen house where
she continued to weep and wail and was
only it was only then again around 719
or 717 there abouts when she was allowed
to be back with her husband and she was
screaming oh do not what what have you
done to take him from me God or bring
daddy to him you know Abe loves him so I
mean it had to have been such a poignant
night back to the what ifs you've got
two left here and it follows on this
discussion it what if after the
assassination of Lincoln all went to
pieces and the presidential transition
process fell prey to momentary passions
and fears yeah yeah I mean you know I
went to Yale I got a BA from Yale a
masters from the London School of
Economics and a PhD from Yale University
again and I figured that the transition
mechanism vice-president becoming
president was all very simple and laid
out that the president dies Vice
President becomes president
end of story in fact the picture was far
murkier and far more complex in
1865 because as it turns out when I went
to go check this question the founders
did not intend for the vice president to
become president
they only intended for the vice
president to temporarily act as
president until there was an election
and at that point then there would be a
new president and so on that fateful
evening when when when Lincoln was shot
and Seward was ailing with five wounds
and Johnson who nobody ever expected to
be president and would met with Abraham
Lincoln only once by happenstance on the
day of the assassination for thirty
minutes ever yeah no no no Deering
Deering just during the second term
before that right right but not well and
and we've stood to this day we still
don't know what they talked about and
and Johnston was widely written off as a
buffoon in Washington circles in fact
during the second inaugural the Attorney
General while Johnson was kind of
rambling on and on because he was drunk
that night the Attorney General said
take that deranged man out of there
that's how low regard a little regard
they held Andrew Johnson and so that
evening the temptations for a Regency or
for a cabinet style government in fact
as I was saying earlier Edwin Stanton
was basically running things for the
first day and a half for Regency or
cabinet style government were great or
for that matter for a military style
intervention you know after the
assassination of Lincoln there'd be such
turmoil such chaos and anarchy gripping
the Union Capitol in fact the New York
Times would editorialized if this were
France all the country would be in
bloody revolution by 24 hours they
weren't such turmoil that the Union
Cabinet would soon be discussing whether
or not in effect a Napoleonic who was
under way and who did they think was
behind it none other than one of their
greatest generals bill Sherman and
that's why I think it's so important to
go back and kind of recreate the world
not as we see it with hindsight but as
they saw it so we can see the turning
points that they confronted last what if
if Joe Johnston had not decided to
disobey Jefferson Davis's orders who was
Joe Johnston yeah Joe Johnston was the
other principal Confederate commander in
the field beyond robert e lee so after
Lee surrendered joe johnson was still
out there and Johnston and Sherman had
been engaged in 10 days of extensive
negotiations about what was to come next
and Jefferson Davis the Confederate
President sent orders to Johnston in
which he basically said fight on imagine
those words ringing like a klaxon in his
head but Johnson's final actions were
not to do what to do what Davis said but
his final act is really an act of
disobedience he said no and he concluded
a surrender there following Lee's
example and and by doing that he played
a great role in sort of helping heal the
country but the irony is is his last act
was not as a good military man was
really into finding his own Confederate
President on the back of your book there
are endorsements yeah how did you get
the following people to endorse this
book Doris Kearns Goodwin James
McPherson Paul Johnson Doug Brinkley
Gary Gallagher and Robert dally
yeah well it's a pretty diverse
cross-section of people and you know if
you think about you know you've Doris
Kearns Goodwin appeal at surprise winner
obviously James McPherson who I didn't
know and you know Paul Johnson were
getting back to the ideological question
there's kind of an ideological spectrum
there basically we sent the book to all
of them and we sent it not in the
finished manuscript but in typewritten
manuscript so it was these people were
awfully nice to have waded through this
this typewritten manuscript and to be
honest I went to the people who I
thought were the very best and who I
most admired as much as anyone whether
it's Doris Kearns Goodwin or Macpherson
or Paul Johnson you know in Bob Dalek is
all I mean in Gary Gallagher and and I
mean they're just all terrific people
and and I just was really touched that
they had those kind words to say about
the book when did you get out of Yale I
was originally class of seven 1979 I
graduated in 1980 and got my PhD
actually much later in 1993 where did
you go right after you after Yale I you
know I didn't want to be a lawyer that
was the only thing I knows I didn't want
to be a lawyer and I sort of wanted this
you know back in those days it was the
foreign policy the great issue of the
Cold War that was one of the hot things
to do and I was interested in it I went
to the London School of Economics got my
masters in international relations and
it sort of opened up a whole new world
for me and then where did you start
working in Washington yeah I started
basically working Washington in about
1984-85 one les Aspin the Democratic
congressman
became chairman of the House Armed
Services Committee hee hee and I serve
knew each other I'd been writing some op
eds in the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal and we knew each other
that way and he said why don't you come
down work for me and I was serve a young
kid I was kind of fresh and green and
not very schooled in the ways of
Washington but I got a quick baptism and
Fire by becoming one of his closest
aides on his congressional staff on the
on the House Armed Services Committee
staff and I mean I did everything from
writing speeches to to doing analyses of
us-soviet relations to to assessments of
arms control and all the rest and and
that's really what I did for a number of
years until about 1990 and that's when I
decided or 1991 and that's when I
decided to take a bride a first book
this is my second but what was your
first book my first book was called on
the Broncos about the end of the called
how did it do it got a lot of attention
got a lot of critical acclaim ruffled a
few feathers but it didn't do nearly as
well as this why did it ruffle a few
feathers it it ruffled a few feathers
because ultimately I came out and I said
that Ronald Reagan will go down in
history is one of the predominant
presidents and was was where it was
really instrumental in in in the end of
the Cold War and and in my view was is
that Reagan was a more sophisticated
more nuanced two leader and you know it
took me four years to get to that point
and when I started writing the book the
last thing I wanted to do was gone say
Ronald Reagan was a critical factor in
all this but by the end of the book I
just felt that that's really where the
evidence weighed and I actually kind of
was furiously rewriting things to
suggest that that history will be much
more kind and much more generous to him
and but because the book was written
fairly recently after the end of the
Cold War partisan passions are still
high and you know just as if you had
written a book about Franklin Roosevelt
shortly after World War two it would
have ruffled a lot of feathers I mean
that's what happens when people who are
still part of that those administrations
are around history usually sorts those
things out and I took my first crack at
history there when did you start this
when you start your research here and
can you remember a moment where you said
April 1865 you know where I said April
1865 or that was that's the what
was about yeah I think really going into
the proposal writing process I wanted to
I mean I sort of focused on the idea of
this April 1865 but I wasn't sure the
meaning of it the extent of it or the
richness of it and in one of the things
that's clear to me now having written
two books and especially after writing
it for 1865 is what you think you're
going to say going into the book will be
very different from what you eventually
come out saying and there are a number
of moments during a book where you
really get hit with an epiphany Epiphany
and things start rushing together and
you say this is very different from what
I thought I want to capture this so when
did you begin to focus on exactly what
you're going to conclude yeah and what
did you go through to get there I mean
you mentioned going to the Ford's
Theatre and down to Richmond and
battlefields right right right
it I mean sort of midway through the
book I was writing the story and in
midway through the book and I started
writing this and about you know the last
four years I've been writing it the
first two years was research and writing
somewhere around year two things started
coming together to me and the way I
write is I don't hand in dress to the
the publisher and I'm sort of putting
them on notice for my next book what I
do is I write the entire book and then I
actually sit down with my wife my wife
lyric Winnick she's also a talented
writer and author in her own right and
we edit this thing at great length every
single paragraph every single sentence
every single word has been edited and
pruned in here and and I think it's
important for a writer to serve right so
people feel like this is an enjoyable
experience that it reads well that it
serve comes alive that's evocative and
and that's that's what that's what I
really labor to do with the good
assistants with my wife lyric and that
process takes at least about six months
but I think it really pays dividends I
don't know how many people have come up
to me they said they've read this book
they've got tears in their eyes it's
really moved them and and it reads like
a novel and I think that's because I put
so much effort into giving it that kind
of aura and feeling when did you know
you're at you went on the New York Times
bestseller list when did you know that
you had a winner yeah
you know anyone who writes a book who
thinks this thing is kind of game doubt
is just it's not the world that I
and because anything can happen every
time the book was read it came back with
the same response so when did I I always
felt I had a winner from from really day
one once the book was done I felt there
was nothing more I could do my goal was
always to write the best book I could
and then it's up to the rest it's up to
the rest of the world and I felt I wrote
the best book I could but from the time
that Doris Kearns Goodwin said that you
know this is a superb piece of history
and I'm a remarkable you know I'm a
marvellous storyteller with a remarkable
tale to tell to what Paul Johnson said
PW gave it a starred review and they
said it Publishers Weekly gave it a
starter review saying this book is a
triumph and that I'm a master
storyteller and then it just kind of
continued on there but you know even
Peter Jennings I don't know if I should
be saying this on TV Peter Jennings
heard me on NPR and he said he wept
hearing me talk about the book and then
he said he started his reading and he
just called me up as a fan and I was I
was very touched by that
what are they weeping about I think
they're weeping about how how for
example people like robert e lee you
know that men can beyond what we deem
now is the wrong side and you can have
such character and dignity and and sort
of hope against hope rather than giving
it to the passions of the day that they
can really that they can sort of give of
themselves in a sense let me give you a
quick example of that you know after the
end of the war you know the south wasn't
the south was in tatters it was a
defeated ruined country and of course
the institution of slavery was turned
upside down and was gone and there's
this poignant scene that takes place in
st. paul's church st. Paul's churches in
Richmond you can go there today it's a
beautiful church I've actually been to a
wedding there for one of my wife's
closer friends and and and the Charles
Monroe the the rector was giving the was
giving the the sermon and at a certain
point it came time for communion quite
unexpectedly shattering years of
tradition a black man walks up to that
to the Chancery rail and he kneels down
ready to take communion and at this
point everybody tenses they're wondering
my god this has never happened certainly
not in the Church of the elite
and and all of a sudden quite
unexpectedly a man who has served his
hair is kind of thinned on top and he's
got a mid-level there and and he looks
sort of tired and beaten and worn down
and he serves Ollie walks up and this is
a man who who just days earlier said I
am defeated I am homeless and penniless
I have nothing left to live for
and that man knelt down to take
communion next to this black man setting
tone for what would for what should come
next in the south and that of course was
robert e lee that was a poignant scene
there's another thing that and I've
talked about it before the authors but
it's still every time we read he can't
believe it happened
the McClellan Lincoln visit right right
it it defies imagination explain that
whole story well I assume you're talking
about when when Abraham Lincoln comes to
McClellan's house and he wants to talk
about the progress of war and Lincoln
his time of the war is this 1860 he was
still in charge it's a team Italy
because he 18 yeah quit and then ran
against him yeah it doesn't matter so
much that it was it was not the right no
it's in the earlier stages of the war
and and and Abraham Lincoln comes in
with his Secretary of State and and he
wants to meet with the meet with magento
McClellan McClellan McClellan comes in
walks up the stairs and Lincoln has kept
waiting for a full hour and after a full
hour McClellan sends word down to
Lincoln he won't meet with him he'll
meet with him the next day that is
unthinkable in this day and age with a
president and a commanding general and
what it tells us is is it tells us that
the kind of stature that Lincoln had you
know we were V R Lincoln I mean I know I
revere Lincoln and I love Lincoln and
he's he's so crucial to this country but
in his day and age he was as hated as he
was loved and if he walked into a room
he wouldn't sort of fill it the way
presidents do today and one other little
footnote you know the night that he went
to Ford's Theater he invited 13 separate
people to come with him and they turned
him down this was the man who was the
president of the surrender of Appomattox
and somehow 13 people turned him down
imagine it happening with a John F
Kennedy or with a with a Bill Clinton or
with a Ronald Reagan and be unthinkable
you use words with all three principles
grant Lincoln Lee
anxiety depression and fatigue and how
many times I read it they were exhausted
beyond all belief what did you pick up
about that and why what's with all the
anxiety in the fee not not they could
have what what did you learn about that
yeah yeah well you learn about it it's
it's war as serious business you know in
in in in Grant's case let's take that
for example I mean grant just before
Appomattox grant had had this pounding
headache this migraine headache and he
was using mustard plasters and all sorts
of other homeopathic remedies to take
care of it and and and he was ailing he
was ailing it was only when he got word
of that Lee would surrender and he said
quite by magic it was gone the headache
was gone and I mean that the stress and
the terrors and the difficulties of war
which is great you know in in Lee's in
Lee's case he had a bad back he had
diarrhea he may have even suffered a
heart attack mid in the war and somehow
throughout all this these men kept
pushing themselves they didn't have
fancy hospitals to go to her fancy
doctors somehow they pushed their bodies
to the limit and of course in Lincoln's
case as I was saying earlier
his hands were clammy he was thirty
pounds underweight he was he was
routinely sick the stresses of the war
were so great and let me let's give a
way to think about this any general who
has to send men to their debts and waves
a thousand after thousands after
thousands after has this kornel of
remorse eating away at them and so
Abraham Lincoln is so Robert Elia so US
Grant had to have this kernel of remorse
eating away at them for for what was
going over what was taking place what
was the total number of dead at the end
of the Civil War six hundred twenty
thousand casualties I mean it's just it
Dwarfs any other conflict and in our
history its unfathomable at the end you
do something different you talk about a
lot of people and I wrote all their
names down in their ages that they were
at the end of civil war yeah thank you
for picking up on this well I did Henry
Ford was - yeah Frank Woolworth thirteen
Richard Sears - Thomas Edison 18
Alexander Graham Bell 18 Samuel Gompers
15 john d rockefeller 26 Andrew
Carnegie xxx Henry Clay Frick 16
Frederick Remington 4 and then you have
Hiram revels of Mississippi was in in 18
he turned out to be the in 1870 the
first United States Senator of black the
black race PT Barnum was 55 he's 55 at
the end of the war yeah he hadn't
started his circus yet he had all these
other these other other careers and his
his greatest career was still ahead of
him why did you do that what was your
point on that well well you know earlier
we had talked about sort of epiphanies
or things that come to you in the
process of writing and this was really
one of them somewhere in the process of
writing April 1865 I decided I wanted to
write a snapshot of America and also the
men who had gone to shape America for
the next 20 50 75 years and so wherever
they wore whatever they were doing
I just wanted to capture them and this
you've just read the list of a number of
the people who I serve right where they
wore and what they were doing and what
really so struck me about all this is
that more often than not most of them
were failures in life and considered to
be failures you know in it with Henry
Ford I talked about how his father says
Oh Henry's not much of anything he's a
tinkerer his father's convinced he's
going to be or is going to be a failure
in life or Thomas Edison just gets fired
from yet another job and he's sort of
drifting around aimlessly and in what
that really tells you is a lot of life
is persistent it's hard work and it's
just when everything is seems to be in
it alone steps somehow leaders find a
way or people who will become great
figures in history somehow find a way to
overcome it it's a real lesson in life
as much as anything else do you have a
favorite chapter that's a you know
that's what I always ask the people who
read the book I say what's your favorite
chapter what's your part of the book and
and more if not my favorite is different
from other people there are two chapters
that I feel I mean it's very hard for me
to say which I'm more attached to I I
love the chapter that has leads retreat
because just from a standpoint of just
sheer drama and the craft of writing I
think it really serves and stores and it
holds and grips the reader and I also
love the the prelude which I have of
April 1865 the introduction most Civil
War
more often than not they will start out
with a more traditional setting like the
Mexican War I start out April 1865 in of
all places Monticello would Thomas
Jefferson in a reason why I did that is
because I felt Thomas Jefferson a slave
owner in one hand who also wrote the
Declaration of Independence a great
empire nation builder on one hand and
yet nobody was more of a fervent
believer in state rights I sort of felt
that Jefferson seemed to embody the
contradictions that would lead to the
civil war in a way he was a guiding
spirit for both sides in the Civil War
and more interestingly when I went to
Monticello
I learned that you know on the eve of
April 1865 Monticello it turns out had a
northern owner it had a southern owner
it was cared for by neither and that for
me seemed to be a telling metaphor for
the country now I should say getting
back to the craft of writing this book
this was probably the hardest thing to
write in the entirety of the book it had
to be rewritten several times when the
draft got to the publisher thanks and
good measure to the wonderful assistance
of my wife an extensive revision process
it was in pretty good shape but that was
one of the parts that really had to be
served redone and redone and it wasn't
clear to me how do I get from here to
there to make it work finally it came
out so I'm attached to that one as well
you talk about Thomas Jefferson there's
a one line heroine to ask you about in
1800 you write he soberly warned that
quote a single consolidated government
would become the most corrupt government
on earth unquote why did you put that in
there and what do you think he'd think
if he saw things today yeah yeah I'm not
sure that's a snake spit I'd totally
want to walk into you know the politics
of back then don't totally translate
into the politics today but it is clear
that Jefferson Davis who was was an
agrarian who believed in smaller
government local was better at every
level if one were to go back in time and
so tell him this is what the government
looks like he would surely be appalled
by it but having said that I'm not sure
that it totally translates into today
because Thomas Jefferson is also
somebody who liberals love as well so it
was a partial answer so did you meet
characters in this book you want to
write more about you know most of them I
would love to write more about I'd love
to write more about Robert Ely I'd love
to write more about Thomas Jefferson
I'll have to read more about us grant
and Abraham Lincoln you know one of the
great things about this book for me as
the author is a you know I was much of
the writing was taking place during the
whole Monica Lewinsky saga and
everyone's talking about leadership
leadership where his leadership and
where his character innocent net I've
got to say it was a great pleasure every
day to wake up and go to my desk and
deal with these figures who would emerge
larger than life and who would be so
critical in saving this country so all
of them I could easily see writing about
again I won't do it for the next book
though you did though create contrast
between William Tecumseh Sherman yeah
and Joe Johnston yeah what role do they
play in this after April 1865 or you
know after the war we thought was over
and why did you compare the two yeah
yeah I compared the two because it's
just that the contrast and their
personalities and their types just
invited comparison you know if you think
of bill Sherman bill Sherman of course
this is Bill Sherman a Union General who
who said War is hell and you cannot
refine it who took Atlanta took Savannah
who took Columbia and cut a swath 422
miles of the South in which he sir
picked clean as he put it he was knows
mattock he was volatile he was a you
know Bill Sherman is someone who I like
enormous Lee I think he'd be great to be
at a dinner party with he would be
fascinating he was a great intellect he
spoke his mind I sort of liked what he
said about journalists although I'm not
going to say what he said go ahead and
repeat it it basically was something to
the effect of I'm close uh you know he
said God God Dan knows does journalists
that uh that you know if you died and
went to hell they'd still be there I
mean he really despised journalists and
in fact he tried to imprison one and
court-martial him even though it didn't
make any sense but but Sherman was just
he was a great military man but he was a
fascinating character you know in the
South today and you know I've been on a
14 city book tour and I've been all over
the country I've been East Coast West
Coast in the south
Sherman is still reviled in much of the
South today but the irony is as Sherman
said you know when this war is over I
will share with you my last cracker the
fact is is he actually loved the South
it was his love for the South that serve
led him near the end
try to give as generous as terms as
possible now in the case of Joe Johnson
he was a kind of prim upright Virginian
who who who is much more staid and much
more proper than Sherman was although
the two of them had this marionette
dance in instead of late 1864 in which
they kind of chased each other zigzag in
fact Johnson even inflicted some serious
blows at one battle against against
Sherman and at one point
Sherman banged on his dinner table he
says my god what is Joe Johnson's game
where where is he today because he had
escaped from Mizzou grasp and this is
another example of two men who became
very close in life as a result very
close bonding as a result of their war
experiences and you know what's so
fascinating and though I don't put this
in the book when Sherman died Joe
Johnson was selected to be a pallbearer
at his funeral and it was a cold misty
rainy day and and Johnson didn't have a
hat on and somebody said to him he said
well why don't you put on a hat because
it's so cold and Misty and of course by
then Joe Johnston's a very elderly man
and Johnson straightens himself up and
says well Sherman would not do this for
me and I will do the same for him and
Joe Johnson died something like nine
days later of pneumonia how did they end
it what's the Bennett House story yeah
the Bennett house story is the story
that we never hear about Appomattox is
usually viewed as the end of the war in
April ninth but of course as I was
saying there's still three Confederate
armies in the field 175,000 men Davis
calling for guerrilla warfare five days
later there's a tripartite assassination
attempt of Lincoln Andrew Johnson and
Seward unions in total chaos and what
takes place in Bennett house in North
Carolina is the final surrender of the
other principle army of the Confederacy
which is commanded by Joe Johnston and
in it's a ten days worth of negotiations
where John's Sherman first sits down
with Johnston and John Breckinridge who
is a former vice president and and in
Breckinridge would join him for the
negotiations at one point the
Confederates will be laying down such
terms and and and Sherman will move his
chair back and say we'll see here who's
who's surrendering to home
and but in fact Sherman will give very
generous terms to the Confederates and
in doing so he thinks he's carrying out
Lincoln's vision but he will be sharply
rebuked by the by the Union Cabinet
particularly after the death of Lincoln
the assassination and a grant will
actually be sent down to talk to Sherman
now this is a fascinating scene too
because in the Union Capitol and this
happens the Attorney General James speed
will say well what if Sherman decides to
arrest Grant and speed and Stanton were
convinced that Sherman was potentially
thinking of some kind of a coup and as
they put it he was getting ready to
march northward with his legions to take
over that's the kind of chaos and
Anarchy that was gripping the North post
Lincoln assassination while they're
still Confederate armies in the field so
if Johnson had decided to go to the
hills and along with Lee to search
sanctioned some kind of guerrilla
warfare we would been in a real mess but
Johnston instead followed Lee's example
and and in he too would surrender as we
said earlier in his act of basic
basically insubordination and in doing
so it would really pave the way for this
country to become not like the Balkans
not like the Middle East not like weapon
in our Cambodia these other civil war
torn countries or Northern Ireland but
to become like America today so was John
Wilkes Booth working on his own yeah
that's a it's a great question and it is
one I don't know the answer to very few
issues did I duck in my own mind when I
went into this book whenever I went into
an issue I wanted to resolve it in its
entirety that was something I felt is
really beyond just the scope of the book
in one hand and for that matter the
scope of my own knowledge that's all
lifetimes worth of work I my sense is he
was not working in concert with the
Confederate government per se but I also
say in a footnote somewhere in the
endnotes that that he may have had a
relationship with the Confederate Secret
Service you know in our time we've known
the CIA to have a number of rogue
operations which has been sanctioned by
sort of higher-ups but out of the
highest levels and something like that
might have happened with Wilkes Booth
but if there's one thing that I was
struck by what John Wilkes Booth many
historians kind of talk about this kind
of cockamamie rogue group that he has
which is I was kind of pitiful and my
sense is is quite different however sort
of impromptu in him
revised this district that he assembled
of assassins was the fact of the matter
is is how close they almost came to
decapitating the entire union government
I mean that's really stunning did I read
that footnote that you said that the the
Secret Service and the Confederates had
something like 800 some thousand dollars
to do you do a project in the North yeah
I think that's probably right it's a lot
of money back then yeah yeah but again
as I'm going to duck this one that's I
mean I know this from other sources it
is a lot of money but let's look at this
in context we do know that Jefferson
Davis at another point and this you know
when when Sherman was ravaging the South
a type of warfare that robert e lee
explicitly rejected attacking you know
attacking innocents and cities and
indeed populating whole state cities
Jefferson Davis turned down a proposal
by his own men to send smallpox infested
blankets into the north so I don't think
that the south is willing to go that far
what's your next book my next book is
going to be as different and it's kind
of bold and the sweeping as this book
but on a very different subject rather
than write a you know in one hand I'd
love to write about the Civil War again
because I have a whole body of knowledge
and it would make my life a lot easier
and certainly my wife's life and my
family life but I want to be challenged
I want to write something different and
if I feel excited and enthused about it
I'm convinced I can make readers equally
enthused it'll probably be about the
world of the 1780s to 1790s our guest is
Jay Winik here is the book 1885 the
month that saved America thank you very
much